son frère hussein mais si tu veux
j'aurais aimé une lgv jouabilité je te
fais laurent voulzy
attention mathieu où nous faites vous
dit bonjour aux téléspectateurs à la
saint patrick sébastien roché ces partis
girouette et le majeur
[Applaudissements]
comme attendu
par les pompiers mais t'as vu qu'à
l'émission par rexel avait obéi c'est
complètement la chine ce mec mais c'est
pas mal à saisir balles et ballons on
peut dire
c'est que d'amour et voisines jan du
plessis
alors à celui très bonnes conditions
vivent les zizis daniel avoue attention
ça fait que de l'amour bonjour c'est
vrai ça c'est génial ça va être génial
en fait n'avait pas du tout changé de
bord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean michel mr l'on fait tourner le cac
est
aussi en bout ce qui s'invente son
plongeon
c'est sa force axiale hashtag naufrage
salut les p'tits sardines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sans déconner tu de triche
on a compris merci suis content d'être à
côté petit team ce qui me sauve tout le
temps presse et lui il a dit je sais pas
qui ressemble à oui je ne vois pas donc
jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
c'était un frère hocine mais si tu veux
j'aurais aimé une lgv jouabilité je te
fais laurent voulzy
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est dans le rôle je me suis alors là
pouvez déjà commencer à tweeté hashtag
naufrage une fois de
la piscine à aller ni opel alors on va
voir là là je vous le dis là ça va être
une succession de nos frères
là là je vous dis là là là outre les
quatre là c'est la séquence titanic
après on savait la s arrêta drame allez
c'est parti on y va aussi vous allez
vous aura 12 c'est génial et vient
surtout bmp je vis de la tob
donald trump
c'est dire pas ta famille
vous avez encore une famille des gens à
à ça c'est pas un peu honte d autant que
nous
benjamin castaldi a cessé ses batteries
brandir et son père
[Applaudissements]
restera jamais connu avant que ce soit à
ce point habite jackie et michel
inquiétez pas je prends jackie et michel
la sauce savait que ça allait être un
naufrage
c'est quoi ah ben non mais là c'est plat
long des rames là on est bon et là on
envoyait les plongeurs ont
dit un
oui on a tant d'années restés d'os et
retourne et on va vous dire dans un
autre c'est comme la fellation ça fait
mal au genou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et qu
est ce qu il avait dit la veille ça
l'homme est retourné ça ne peut pas se
répéter
retournez-vous romeo
allez donc j mais non
non mais qui vous a demandé vous
retrouvez
à lézat ben ali fait tourner et
serviettes et je me sers et très parents
d'aller dormir c'est sa serviette
moi je dis ça fait peur
non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tu mérites de l'iphone d'apple
merci vous êtes en direct de mal à
esquiver
alors sa fière de vous
c'est pas pire que c'est pas la pire la
règle c'est vrai bon alors là pas du
tout
je gardais
alors alors
toujours go
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]